[Music]
all right welcome back the true news one
of the first true news episodes out of
the 40-yard that we've got in the
playlist check the right here
I don't forget to subscribe the tg2 as
well by the way because we've got lots
of content coming for their days we're
putting the eyes extra stuff onto g2
that is just beautiful really so the
world might be ending we don't know I
think you're making light of a very sad
situation true news however awkward
situation first time we've had to do
proper news by true news news before
very rarely though we're here to try and
make light of a horrible situation Oh II
I thought it's due serious coverage now
butchers latest message is a bit later
for those who don't know that was the
character in a london-based television
show called EastEnders she was like
slinging a rock called the Grady fact
that something far away which are well
I've got a poet like if I go out which I
won't here's how I go I can we can we
freeze it on when she puts the ballot or
on trying to rob the bank
you know she is the type woman who keeps
it 100 percent real all the time you
wouldn't [__] with her the would you
wouldn't [__] her til no come on you
wouldn't mess around with her she's God
bless her she's a little old lady she
would put anyone in their place I love
this we see a picture on the internet
arsenal of an elderly lady facing empty
shells she could not buy a [__]
- yes a thought I can throw a war and
don't remember anything like this
staff was rationed but we all got our
share because stuff was rationed
stockpiling no you couldn't she's still
making good points to me in a way but
she's also not making good points and
I'm gonna call her out for what's on the
robot hearts in the right place sure but
what she's saying is it's wrong raishin
didn't stockpile know that generation
didn't stop they didn't have the [__]
ability to love don't talk [__] like
it's these [__] people who walk
around invoking the war on every [__]
thing lean into [__] covet like you
lent into [__] brexit love and I'm
sure we'd be alright the stores should
be letting people oh yeah one per
customer one what one what one pack what
you roll them why don't you [__] say
she's making a [__] run people
shouldn't be in [__] grandkids are
gone say this stuff grandma people
shouldn't be able to just buy whatever
they want
she's right people exploiting old people
she talk about old people being
exploited she's being exploited for
views by some [__] grandkid now yeah
oh stop crying
within the next week or so when the
toilet prices [__] double the toilet
price is gonna double how many toilets
reckon we're gonna need in the next
eight the point she's making better
people are gonna exploit people and put
[__] on eBay right now baby formula hand
sanitizer things that people feel like
they can't live without good [__] and
some [__] and bloody ebay is charging
[__] 200 quid a bottle what a [__]
wanker yeah fine what a wanker
all right this is also Papa the American
version who just so happens to be
President of the United States and
here's basically the dates where he's
dismissed a covert virus we think we
have it very well under control we
pretty much shut it down coming in from
China you know in April supposedly it
dies with a hotter weather when it gets
warm historically that has been able to
kill the virus people are getting better
they're all getting better and the 15
within a couple of days is going to be
down to close to zero it's going to
disappear one day
it's like a miracle it will dissipate it
that was one of my favorite quotes
because it's like a miracle it will
disappear I was like where are you
getting this stuff from variability
false true yeah that's him yeah we're
all really working out and a lot of good
things are gonna happen and we are
responding with great speed and
professionalism it's gonna go away
yeah no I don't take responsibility at
all gonna all be great whether it be so
good this came up but it we came up so
suddenly this is a pandemic I felt it
was a pandemic long before it was called
a pandemic all you had to do is look at
other countries how anyone can defend
this you are a bullshitter you're a liar
hold it from the start he said this
pandemic will die out and very few
people get it but it could also be a
pandemic lots of people could die or no
people would have seen it from the deal
well yeah they did say that pandemic the
corona virus you know
this is their new hoax we call that a
hoax in a many ways Brian it is a hoax
in many booths mmm but I can't think of
the ways right now but it is a hoax
we're 15 people in this massive country
and because of the fact that we weren't
early we went early we could have had a
lot more than that we're doing great
our country is doing so great what does
one when early mean Laura when early
well I'm not surprising that next press
conference isn't literally like yeah
we're all gonna die we're all dead each
of us I said it though we'd all die yeah
but the main thing is we're gonna die in
America diapered of the wrestles will
die free and that's what's important
yeah well done well I've been quite as
you may be at the table either side of
mothers but we are back mother [__]
suppose you guys are wondering at home
what it was like to sit so close to
someone who suffered from CO vid 19 but
was my moment now it was harrowing to
sit so close to someone who was
suffering so badly but I had to make it
through and you can too we didn't know
if you also have to look after a loved
one like I did and please look after me
do you look fine there you patted me on
the shoulder that was as far as it
worked and that was that was just all
the [__] puffs on camera by I think of
everything that happened off camera
nothing as a percentage we supply the
Sun I was 100% you deliver a couple of
times as well I think I bought delivery
room the day when I came over in your
coffee I'm not covering your mouth out
I'll had it happened at the beginning of
February no one was talking about
they're not even Donald Trump well he
was just I've seen the colors the saying
it was Brian no soon it was fine not at
the time obviously we all thought it was
a hope just genuinely yeah if I'd have
known all this [__] a month ago I would
have been a lot more careful around you
how does it feel to know though that you
have been ill with a hoax didn't feel
like a horse when I was [__] sweating
bullets in the bed but it was a hoax so
very real fake illness real you know a
fake illness definitely felt really and
a cheat similarly to Donald Trump the
American media also haven't really been
getting this accurate heavens
nailed the message we've got basically
dates and you know the before and afters
worst worst case scenario it could be
the flu I feel like the more I learn
about this the less there is to worry
about I was about to say the same thing
we don't have immunity to this virus
it's a new virus it's a pandemic strain
of a
we haven't seen before nine days later
it's just like the flu and then the guy
goes the more I hear about it but let's
not worry about it
right come on guys because being better
informed means you won't get the virus
the more you know about it the less I
worry you all the talk about coronavirus
being so much more deadly doesn't
reflect reality without a vaccine the
flu would be far more deadly
we are facing an incredibly contagious
and dangerous virus I love those guys
over at Fox News Club nailing the news
on a daily basis so in America every
year they have a big event known as
Spring Break where they all break from
college get off their tits yeah bro get
[__] yeah literally going yet some
people are willing to give thought of
lawrence no and to be honest Bryan I
don't blame them because this thing
looks [__] incredible right
we've been wait for Miami Spring Break
for a while he's off his tits as this
interview school oh yeah absolutely
look at mine for this for so long Brian
why would you why would you knock this
noise is running as this is going you
don't lose your youth
what is there to do here other than go
to the bars or the beach they're closing
all of it it's really messy I think
they're blowing it way out of proportion
you know what you look for when you go
to spring break you look for a girl Luna
she's been crying all night this girl
does not look like she's been having a
good time this girl looks like she's
stressed she looks like she's had an
eventful evening yeah Brian followed me
in at least two days
now what I'd imagine is that spring
break is very much like the men go out
there and hunt and the women are very
much the hunted
I don't know about that she could join
the other side really she looks like
she's been hunting yeah this girl looks
like she's been chased or Marcia
so this really fun what yeah listen I've
got a hard background but I've been able
to afford to come all the way out Spring
Break so this really sucks
all right it's not because they've seen
hardship in New Orleans as well yeah
remember they had to buy a disturbance
yeah
and then then there's been lots of other
stuff none in New Orleans so it's not a
happy time down there but doesn't mean
that you deserve a good spring break I
mean you do sure she says it's the best
of it this isn't the Titanic good like
you're not being forced to go down on
this ship like you can do things to help
yourself at this point not go yeah she's
just like [__] it because she's a strong
woman and I worry about that it means
that makes me realize how [__] we are
feels like in the UK everyone's
terrified
we're cowardly we're like the opposite
of this where people even just sort of
get within six feet of each other and
they're frightened this lot don't give a
[__] no but that's because none of I
mean up until this point where I saw
this woman on screen I didn't think that
any of them were in the high-risk
category this woman it's not fat shaming
say that someone who is on the bigger
side may be more in danger or illness I
mean blood pressures just a thing
there's a yeah it's quite literally a
thing but yeah that's actually what
Korona says blood pressure it's just a
thing
should we see what's trending on YouTube
see if what about for us what what will
should we bring her back to the UK well
there you go this is a disease that is
so dangerous and so infectious that
without drastic measures to check its
progress it would overwhelm any health
system in the world and I've used the
Italian Health System it is excellent so
we have flex isn't it I've used the
Italian house
the times where as people we have to
just switch off from the [__] at times
but when they start saying serious
things I was right three weeks like
these right now Lucy's right now this
guy [__] a couple of weeks ago is
just like we just need to flatten the
sombreros and now he's like ashes really
[__] serious there'll be no sorrows
for you live yes although flights very a
homebody like me this is sort of really
I'm just staying in all the time it's
really just that you don't get me to
come over anymore that's that is
annoying that he thinks annoying but
people who like traveling that this must
be a real [__] yes it is rather a
[__] for us so makes me laugh a little
bit really don't be laughs when we got
Coronis you know in reality obviously I
rather you guys be able to travel yeah
love that but if there is a byproduct of
this horrible shitty situation yeah
knowing how [__] off all of these
people who like the gamelan get away
yeah because I think a lot of people use
trouble as an escape from real life
I definitely don't always sort of [__]
me off a bit I'm always like oh look you
living for your holiday
in this fund the entire [__] the a
living for one week of the bastard year
and it's like all that week's gone now
probably face reality oh there goes
gravity oh well done Eminem but you
choked ultimately to beat this crisis we
will need a combination of better swords
you know we're gonna need for this I
need some better science yeah quick any
better sign books so can anyone bring
some of that better science in please
mr. Swinburne didn't it shows up much in
school miss yeah I'm really annoyed
because I left my better science at home
today [__] better science
this guy's a [__] Muppet we will need
a combination of better science
technology medicine data
government operations economic support
learning from other countries and social
support is basically saying we need a
brand new [__] country what we need
is a new thing cuz we [__] it up so
bad we're gonna need to completely reset
hey guys sorry all the stuff the women
to be building for ya we got
King blonde can it's [__] Miss Piggy
in a [__] wig sorry guys all the
stuff that we've been thinking we should
prep for we got a bit distracted because
of our [__] egos yeah thankfully we
can consider fishing we will need a
combination of better swords I think
there's some better science that I left
in the back of the living room Brian oh
you [__] fat-ass better [__]
science we're gonna better Science and
Technology I'll just pop down to John
Lewis then shall I in the UK it's our
good friend Sean upward fan of the
podcast render Stroke Awareness Week on
if he especially now because in his
latest video after watching it I was
like alright then well I'm off to [__]
myself
big wood he does his research and it's
like almost to a point where I'm like I
wish II didn't know that much now I just
kind of wonder where Sean goes do you
think he goes on like reddit or theater
plugs under the mirrors yeah Sean is one
of those people just for anyone watching
at home
Sean sometimes says really bad things so
that we react in a way that we go oh
[__] we should probably stop that and
then it stops bad things from happening
so Sean's talk about the worst thing
that can happen here don't let this it's
also his tone that terrifies me in this
like on eating them the people requiring
intensive car are being turned away
there is limited capacity to treat
people at that level of illness and in
some cases they just on the floor in
corridors or a little blanket thrown
over them being left to die
that alone is it's frightening isn't it
it's just hearing that imagine your
loved ones and they go there and then
just being told that [__] off not enough
space no room at the end Sean is
actually quite good at delivering
serious news it makes you feel the
seriousness of it you watch on the news
and they go 10,000 people have had
Korona phone you're like yeah they have
a maid oh well back to dinner you can
tell these feeling he's sad about this
you know again though
don't panic about this because people
are doing things I think did you care of
doing pretty good so far I'm not in
London now I mean I was in a walk past
Marks & Spencer's this morning and it
was just full of people really yeah like
I'm not even sure it was like heaving
with people [__] I told someone to
cover a [__] mouth this morning
really she just stood opposite me and
just went her and I was like cover your
[__] mouth and you looked up and just
went well I'm gonna order a baseball bat
on Amazon News Alert coronavirus could
be spread by [__] scientists say the
pandemic has taken an unexpected turn as
Chinese site this warned the disease
could be spread by [__] I think
that's pretty self-explanatory because
if you can't breathe near someone
probably shouldn't sit your tongue at
the book there is no medical book or
better science set of science that says
rim them how many people out there are
going didn't think that but can you not
logg because if you've already like
kissed someone
surely licking their ass is very similar
now there really doesn't matter at this
point that's all holes and I don't think
that's the logic I mean I think that out
the other end goes the waste you know
but I mean in terms of disease spreading
all I'm saying is if you've already
kissed someone
Poppaea top of Europe now this is
Vanessa Hudgens who said she was by the
way she was - she was sorry she was she
was in high school musical I didn't know
that I only found that out after her
news came out right he did a little more
retail a lot of very pretty woman
obviously but she had a nice Bush I did
think he stroked you I wanted to pet it
right look do you still feel the same
about her after she said this terrible
yeah she was then forced to apologize
for basically saying a reality she got a
one thing right maybe I shouldn't be
doing this
very good point she ain't the person to
be now she's not then that was just a
selfish attitude wasn't it really she's
up there dr. Vanessa Hajus woman's a
dummy a checkup
I preferred uh without her clothes on
and not saying anything you know and for
once I think I can get away with saying
something like that because what she
said was garbage problem with that isn't
that she's saying dumb it's the problem
that so many people care about what
she's got to say is she's got like 30
odd million Instagram followers if she
treats her like it's nothing to worry
about
and so well all of their their followers
socially kids walk downstairs to dinner
and they go listen mom dad it's
inevitable I'm just gonna get it I'm not
sitting yeah I thinking that people will
just nod and act exactly how she is for
influence at that level is serious we're
talking 30 odd million people follow her
like some of them will a lot of them
will be like Oh what apology oh I'm so
sorry for the way I've offended anyone
who was a bloody idea quite sure who
could be offended by that but yeah I
realized my words were insensitive and
not at all appropriate for the situation
this has been a huge wake-up call both
significance to my words
I mean whoever wrote this for her did a
good job away it ties it up in a nice
little package that they did cover or
off like you liked her nice little
package so maybe that's idea the point
is she didn't really need to apologize
for saying it's inevitable that people
are gonna get it I don't think she was
wrong in what she said I I just think
people didn't expect it to come out of
her mouth
it was the insensitivity in which she
just dismissed it was like I'm not gonna
die [__] like I was throughout that it
was clear and and I think that she has
been caught out for not giving a [__]
about other people she can apologize but
the reality is what the reality is like
this was a window into how a lot of
celebrities actually think but they're
just not dumb enough to come up and be
honest about it
a real I love this I really love this
guy so this guy's basically doing an
impression of a Midlands mum there
meeting someone in a suit from so he's
got a lot of characters but this is one
of my favorites
no it's certainly not doctors that's for
sure
yeah yeah friend of mine Susan she
posted an article on Facebook the other
day about how the hand sanitizing gel is
actually a thing spreading the disease
yeah don't bring about that in the
mainstream media do
she reckons but this whole thing spread
in China because someone interfered with
a bap on a third trip to the supermarket
today obviously you should see our house
we got spare room for the pasta off the
carriage for the new roll oh but which
pig would be more understanding about
that yeah young girl served me in that
sig Marquis Indian she said to me excuse
me madam did you need all that toilet
roll I said I denied you need your job
the tongue is especially good can I just
say my favorite bit of this hole was
like the way he says Indian when he goes
everyone's met at wat just like this
yeah yeah can we have a look at the
other current he's got some belt Lusaka
character he's a good guy headache
nasally think think of God it so first
Tom Hanks Idris Elba me the three we've
all tested positive so this affects
celebrities as well as nobody's seen its
the whatsapp I mean with Tom Hanks and
Idris Elba
we call it the mates the mates whatsapp
group ain't that just like us it's a
dress he's gone coughing blah just a bit
I'll gonna reply something use a tissue
brackets not for that exactly the cross
between Gareth Keenan and David Brent oh
yeah in a very perfect way as well is
that their love child isn't he yeah I
also thought hey what's happening at
this time with weird things like
mukbangs
online are they stopping because
obviously with corona turns out not
really no he's absolutely fine
was our fish alive or dead alive
how mean is that why is she acting like
that she's doing it and then she eats
him we're in this mess because people
like started [__] around with [__]
dodgy creatures she thinks should have
learned a [__] lesson think of point
if it looks ugly
Donita yeah and generally I apply that
across the board absolutely yet although
that would definitely mean you get many
less [__] I'm always left with the
same question whenever we watch this
source of thousands upon thousands of
views for people just gorging on weird
[__] seven million views why I get that
a lot of people will watch it for the
same reason we are but a lot of people
like this now why do you like this
they're masturbating some of them must
just like it for other reasons if you do
let us know in the comment I want to
know why the [__] you watched the a a
good one I don't get it so blue van man
I want to know how Dave's dealing with
all of this it has even past any comment
clearly no well he's literally just bit
at the pub five years ago I'm worried
he's mixing with people when we should
be five days ago and Dave's probably I'm
on there vulnerable categories isn't why
they all dress is a different version of
Doctor Who that guy with the scarf and
the heart is love him he's wrapped up
against Corona put the scarf on white
it'll protect your cut cut your corona
you'll catch a car out there my lover I
do like the haircut of the middle fella
Sperry I play bass in a mid 60's get
banned as this is beyond torture
championship good old British spirit in
it pad we carry on we battle through
this worries me that his he's adopting
this witty spirit the carry on and
battle through yeah run and hide it
should be the current spirit absolutely
yeah or or just you know battle through
but alone at home div love you we love
Jude yeah and we want to inspire I don't
he Steve yeah was easy service he is in
a high-risk collection she you guys
locked on yeah just sitting what would
he do just sit and just review food yeah
I don't mind that it's a load but I
couldn't handle it know if anything
happened to Dave we wouldn't it just
wouldn't be what life wouldn't be worth
living yeah
would ya touchwood cuz i know dave does
regularly told me he look like he's
thinking it's not the video that I love
about Dave he knows what will make you
look like a free throw up Babis finger
on the finger on the chin yeah it's been
a Nancy's afternoon that three Leicester
City players have the corona virus
symptoms right symptoms they don't have
it they have symptoms a lot of people
are gonna exhibit the symptoms of corona
virus but they won't actually have the
virus now I've not got Corona why I've
just got the symptoms just to be clear I
think that was a misspoke there yes what
he said they don't have it yeah what he
meant is it's not confirmed yet it's
unconfirmed yeah they're probably have
it on confirm reports yeah I don't
personally think the season should be
scrapped
I do think games should be played I mean
even if he's behind closed doors these
talk of that football is for the fans
and if the fans are there then he's not
football
what body is it is football is football
fans of Plateau travelled many miles and
fans also want a resort to the season I
know I do
I don't want people dying of coronavirus
but I do want to resort to the season is
[__] I don't want to see people die but
we should resolve the Premier League
come on guys every single football file
is feeling the same way in the same way
but it's the way he woods just makes it
look just Milberg let's check on food
with us genuine beautiful anything
happened to him
oh my god so his last upload was two
weeks ago that's good I don't think the
virus got him I think he's just self
isolated I hope it means he's doing some
home cooking I'd like to hear what can
you not put videos I'll just to let us
know you're all right well who knows
food reviewer someone check our missing
him I got the money Instagram right yeah
I do reviews on the YouTube maybe not
much longer never seen such a cool
so far and do you know why no no wasn't
about I don't know what to expect these
two blue raspberry I'm not a fan of red
raspberry let alone blue don't even get
him started
blue is not an isolated I was ever
gifted this monkey thought him that his
girlfriend got him nah he'd be laughing
in her face I want some real chocolate
you know I do love her much and she was
like baby you got all got all this
chocolate over here baby he's like I got
all that white chuckle I'm a poor inside
you did but very attractive still going
for the design still giving us a real
review despite the fact he isn't like
the product it's a deets Manny likes
those deals isn't that enormous hit him
like a woman had said to him like I
don't love you anymore Thailand when you
took to chew thought that's usually a
good sign
free is normally the best alone is it is
not sour he's right but he does not
print pronouncing the word right he's
also so about he's been listen to
Porsche him alone a lot lately he's
putting light into anything what am i
long I love him he almost be almost
vomits there look way a little gag I've
never seen him good I love him oh well
we need to know your okay Tyler so just
let us know I'll message you on on
Instagram and see how you doing but you
know just put some now that people know
you're okay so that was true news this
week sad it's a shitty one isn't it
we'll try to put a bit of happiness in
your lives and that you know obviously
we're taking this seriously but you got
it you got to try and make light of
every situation if you can yeah well not
every situation yeah most close though
yes yeah stay subscribed hit the like
button there's lots of playlist starts
of videos check them out T G 1 2 G 2 TG
3 kill yeah it's all there just lots of
T's yeah all the tits all the time
yeah on the true Joe to YouTube channel
say is that okay